early last week competitive smash was
sent into disarray as the smash World
Tour announced that allegedly they'd
been forced by Nintendo to cancel their
2022 finals suffice it to say the smash
community at large was sent into an
uproar not just because of Nintendo mind
you but Panda Global who in addition to
operating smash's only officially
licensed tournament circuits are being
accused of strong-arming other TOS in
the scene
well actually it's their CEO who's being
accused at least he was their CEO he has
since been ousted and released a 31-page
statement detailing his side of the
story which sparked quite a bit of
backlash
let's talk about it
[Music]
all right so before we dive into this
absolute dumpster fire I want to plug
our merch real quick we now carry the
touchgrass hoodie in multiple colors so
be sure to grab one in time for the
holiday season I wear my brown one all
the time since it is warmest and super
well made and reminds me to get outside
in this all too dreary weather okay so
smash if you're coming into this fresh I
strongly advise that you take a minute
and watch the don't at me that Josh did
last week on the thing that started all
of this the cancellation of the smash
World Tour seriously I'm going to assume
that you've watched Josh's video because
mine sort of won't make sense without it
following said cancellation the smash
Community became understandably incensed
with Nintendo since according to the
statement released by The swt it was
Nintendo who forced the swt to close up
shop on their finals in an effort to
raise money for VG boot camp Ludwig even
announced that he'd be hosting his very
own smash event for the top players from
the smash World Tour which she cheekily
titled the scuffed World Tour but the
community also became incensed with
another tournament organizer one who
happens to operate smash's one and only
officially licensed tournament circuit
Panda global why were they incensed well
that's what we're here to talk about as
soon as the announcement went live
allegations began to surface
corroborating the swt's claim that
Panda's CEO at the time Alan bunny had
been threatening or at the very least
hinting at shutdowns of this sort whilst
trying to Lobby other TOS to sign onto
the panda circuit within no time people
in the smash Community were lashing out
at Panda on mass and singling out bunny
specifically for the role he supposedly
played in sabotaging the smash World
Tour or as Danielle Rosen so aptly
characterized it grimo worm tonguing his
way into the ear of other TOS needless
to say the Fallout
wasn't pretty everyone left from plov to
ibdw to Wadi to TK Breezy to punk to
Vicky Kitty to their freaking talent
manager there were also a lot of reports
of panda employees receiving harassment
over all of this which is of course
inexcusable and disgusting and made
matters that much worse and then on
December 5th Panda announced that Alan
bunny had been ousted as CEO and that
they'd be working with outside advisors
to form a temporary IMC they also
announced that they'd be supporting any
employees who wished to part ways with
panda and last but not least that they'd
be canceling the panda Cup finale the
very next day bunny released his own
statement where he alleged well a lot
it's very long and obviously I cannot go
through the entire thing what I can do
is give you the tldr first off bunny
corroborates what Nintendo claimed in
their public statement which is that
they never told swt leadership that they
wouldn't be able to hold their event
bunny claims that swt leadership must
have misunderstood Nintendo and that
their event was shut down of their own
accord he also seems to make this sort
of weird intimation that the event was
never intended to run in the first place
which was quickly responded to with
evidence that travel accommodations had
in fact been put into place this in turn
drove swt to release yet another
statement which includes a screenshot of
the statement Nintendo allegedly sent
them so as to clear up any questions of
misinterpretation it's hard to imagine
that VG boot camp would have
self-incurred hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of Damages over a simple
misunderstanding with Nintendo but that
is in no uncertain terms exactly what
money is suggesting swt statement also
clarified that their 2022 tournament was
absolutely slated to take place and
reiterated that they had it from
Nintendo in writing that they would not
be able to hold any of their future
events without a license swt also
maintained that they were genuinely just
sort of baffled that bunny would suggest
that the entirety of the 2022 finals was
one big coordinated lie bunny of course
vehemently denies any allegations that
he played any sort of role in sabotaging
tarnishing or in any way affecting swt's
relationship with Nintendo despite the
aforementioned sea of claims that he was
privately telling other TOS that swt
would not in fact receive a Nintendo
license and would eventually have to
close up shop swt leadership clarified
in their statement that they actually
never alleged that buddy sabotaged their
relationship with the Nintendo only with
other TOS which they claim was extremely
detrimental to the health and indeed
existence of their world tour as a whole
as for Beyond The Summit I do want to
highlight that bunny kicks things off
with a sidebar that he's never heard of
the guy named LD who's been saying
things about him which like if you're
portraying yourself as this big shot
event organizer in Smash and you
earnestly have no idea who the BTS guys
are like you're not just pulling some
silly Conor McGregor who is this guy
nonsense I feel like that's not really
something you want to flex anyway bunny
basically alleges that BTS s's former
creative director Ken hotbid Chen had a
vendetta against him yelled at him
whenever they got on the phone together
and stonewalled each and every one of
Bunny's suggestions regarding any sort
of future collaboration in response to
this hodman published a Twitter thread
in which he countered Bunny's claims
alleging that the former Panda CEO was
essentially trying to instill a monopoly
on competitive smash by buying broadcast
rights from every event he could and
bullying TOS into cooperating with him
under threat of using his influence with
Nintendo to shut them down these claims
were quickly corroborated by other TOS
who claimed that Bunny's back alley
pursuit of broadcast rights began after
he realized that they wouldn't be able
to buy the events themselves now this is
important because together VG boot camp
who runs smash World Tour and BTS
compete for the broadcast rights for
virtually every tent pole tournament in
competitive smash The Logical assumption
which LDC summarized succinctly on
Twitter is that bunnies sold Nintendo a
smash circuit without ever actually
having secured the requisite events he
then scrambled to get the events and
when no one wanted to sign on out of
fear of working with someone who by
their own admission is not particularly
experienced in running tournaments he
started coming after the next best thing
broadcast rights and supposedly that's
when the strong arming began look I may
not know a ton about smash but I have
been a DOTA die hard since 2009. I've
been following BTS since the beginning
and have been an avid fan of hotbed
Since The Brood War days he LD and BTS
as a whole are trusted and respected
across the whole of Esports so if your
whole defense relies on the premise that
these extremely well-liked individuals
who everyone else is corroborating are
in fact conniving self-destructive Thugs
who are out to torch you your company
and the smash scene as a whole I mean
well
good luck to be clear that is not me
taking a side I think that there is a
lot to parse here including the
genuinely good things that Panda has
done for smash as a whole what I am
saying is that to base one's claims on
what is essentially an uncorroborated
character assassination of BTS is
bold anyway the general takeaway from
Bunny's statement is that he sees
himself as this sort of Savior who by
bringing everyone into Panda's tour and
giving them Nintendo licenses was going
to legitimize Smash and turn it into a
tier 1 esport I'm being a little bit
glib about it obviously but that really
is the sentiment and substance it
conveys unfortunately one of the ways
that bunny allegedly wanted to make
smash go mainstream was to eventually
abandon melee altogether what do you
think about you know potentially
assigning me you know what would get
that ground rolling to
have we sponsored uttered panda
and straight up what Dr Allen told me
was like
yeah you know the thing is is that I
don't really believe in melee the
numbers just aren't there
like I I believe in Ultimate more
because you know there's all these
YouTube numbers and then you look at
melee's YouTube numbers and it's just
not there and you know if I were to sign
Someone Like You It's like I would like
maybe I would maybe give you like 500 a
month it also seems as if at some point
money may have started setting his eye
on non-smash events in regards to just
like buying out everything and just like
owning all of it in terms of all the
smash events and stuff it doesn't stop
it just smash
from what I have been what I've heard
what I've been privy to smash is not the
only thing that he was like I'll just
buy it all out and we'll run all of it
not the only like that's not the the end
of what
of their future Empire in another
timeline
so I I totally believe that that
happened because that makes perfect
sense now to be fair Panda as an entity
has honestly done good things for smash
even as a tournament organizer and it is
a genuine shame what has happened to the
company and its employees as a result of
all of this the real issue it seems is
that by making Nintendo aware or even
just concerned about broadcasting rights
being sold in the space Bunny and Panda
may have made it so that the developer
threatens legal action against TOs and
broadcasters which would quite literally
destroy competitive smash forever as of
right now there's no indication that
that will happen that said the situation
is still very much unfolding and we'll
let you know as soon as there's more to
tell until then
fingers crossed that none of this causes
irreparable damage to smash
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock